[Music]
on this tuesday night lowering
temperatures and rising covid cases
concerns about what could happen this
winter the last thing that we want to do
is is move backwards news about booster
shots for any canadian aged 18 and over
and the conservative leader makes it
clear he has lost patience with vaccine
skeptics in his caucus vaccines are safe
delicate tasks another search for
unmarked graves at one of canada's
longest running residential schools a
reality check on the promises made at
cop26 but we still have a mountain to
climb and a new assessment about how
fast the world is warming
plus celebrating 100 years of the puppy
how the delicate flower came to
represent remembrance
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with developments around
covid19 health canada has now approved a
booster of the pfizer biontech covet
vaccine for everyone 18 years old and up
to maintain their protection against the
virus the booster can be given at least
six months after people got their second
dose third doses are already being given
in some provinces to high-risk groups
including people 70 and older indigenous
people and front-line health care
workers health canada is also reviewing
an application for the booster dose of
the moderna vaccine
as winter approaches covet 19 case
counts are creeping up it's happening so
fast in yukon a state of emergency has
now been reimposed there yukon has the
highest per capita rate of active cases
in the country mass mandates and
capacity limits including in outdoor
settings are being put in place and the
nunavuk region in northern quebec has
the highest covid19 infection rate since
the pandemic began nunovic reported 259
active cases on monday that's about 1450
cases per 100 000 people
the community of saluit is a hardest hit
nearly 200 cases among 1200 people at
least five patients have been
transferred from nunavut to hospitals in
southern quebec nunavik's health board
says 80 percent of people who have
tested positive are not fully vaccinated
vaccinations are key here and 85 percent
of eligible canadians are now fully
vaccinated but as winter closes in and
we spend more time indoors the risk as
eric sorensen reports has not been
completely eliminated
winter's coming outdoor patios are
closing and restaurant patrons are
moving indoors something else will also
be moving inside viruses including covet
19.
life is more normal now than a year ago
in ontario capacity limits have been
lifted on restaurants and gyms along
with big sporting events and theaters
now comes the next big test canadians
coming together in greater numbers
indoors but also protected by vaccines
we are moving forward the last thing
that we want to do is is move backwards
and go into a further lockdown that's
what we don't want that the people of
ontario don't want that in ontario since
the last big wave in the spring with
more than 4 300 cases a day the numbers
have stayed low but are beginning to
trend upward from a seven day average
below 350 a day at the end of october to
492 cases now one expert says it's too
soon to end all restrictions with the
delta variant lurking
there is no way out without public
health measures we need to have a little
bit of these restrictions including the
certificates including the masking and
probably a bit of capacity restrictions
in the province the country is in a
better place epidemiologists say we can
look at the numbers differently now
nationally after a surge of cases in
september the numbers are rising
slightly once more but hospitalizations
are still coming down and the average
number of deaths is falling the question
if another wave of cases comes will
hospitalizations and deaths also rise it
does not necessarily mean we're going to
see the same type of spiking
hospitalizations that we saw last year
with the large blanket of a vaccination
we have in our community this will
actually make it so it's much less
comparatively than it was for example
last year sudbury ontario is
implementing capacity limits again after
a new outbreak in the city localized
restrictions not province-wide lockdowns
may become the norm what is needed now
is just defined fine-tuned response that
takes into account the local
epidemiological situation but i think
that we do have to realize that we are
in a very different landscape
right now as outdoor temperatures fall
experts believe covet cases will rise
but keeping down serious cases and
deaths will be the key to a public
health victory this winter erik sorensen
global news toronto
in the u.s the pandemic is at a
crossroads as the holiday season
approaches and americans travel and
spend more time indoors kovid 19 is
still killing more than 1 000 americans
every day case counts are creeping up
nearly half of the states are now
reporting higher numbers as jackson
proskow explains it's leading to a new
urgency to get more people vaccinated
fast
when visitors arrive in the u.s they'll
find a country still very much in the
grips of the pandemic with daily case
rates on average almost four times
higher than in canada every single day
the u.s still records an average of 1200
covid related deaths and is on track to
exceed 1 million deaths by march
everybody is going to have to really
start thinking a little bit like an
epidemiologist and think about what
their what their own risk level is and
what the risk tolerance is going to be
in many states the virus is surging
again two months ago the delta variant
led to an explosion of cases in florida
texas and the south today the situation
has reversed with northern states like
minnesota michigan and vermont seeing
the fastest rates of increase vermont
also has one of the highest rates of
vaccination in the u.s at 72 percent we
know now that fully vaccinated people
can have breakthrough infections and
especially older ones could be more
susceptible to serious breakthrough
infections so it's a it's a risk all of
that is creating uncertainty about the
winter as people gather indoors travel
is expected to return to pre-pandemic
levels for american thanksgiving and the
holidays well it's anybody's guess as to
exactly what's going to happen here and
and i think that they're trying to
predict
exactly where we're going
is going to be complicated because there
are so many factors involved vaccination
remains the biggest factor of them all
pfizer has asked the fda to authorize
booster shots for anyone over age 18 to
top up their immunity yet in many parts
of the country too many people still
haven't received their first shot and
remain entirely unvaccinated
that suggests covid and its very real
risks aren't going away soon
as americans remain divided over how to
live with a virus that has taken away so
much
jackson prosko global news washington
the federal conservative party leader
aaron o'toole says he is a firm believer
in the safety and effectiveness of
vaccines but some of his mps are not a
civil liberties caucus was started by a
group of tory mps including ontario's
marilyn gladu to advocate for the
unvaccinated gladu has downplayed the
severity of covid19 today though she did
an about-face and retracted the comments
david aiken reports on the political
headache for aaron o'toole
welcome back to the hill update i'm your
host dean allison on the weekly tv show
that he hosts conservative mp dean
allison has been bringing on guests and
together they have been questioning the
effectiveness of vaccines that we should
be recognizing natural immunity alison
is also the sponsor of two e-petitions
in the house of commons one calls on the
government to approve ivermectin as a
treatment for covid health canada has
already warned canadians it is dangerous
to take that drug and the other petition
asserts that vaccines are not proven
safe and that vaccine passports should
be banned
but it is not just allison at least five
other conservative mps have also been
raising concerns about vaccines on
social media in petitions and in news
columns and that is creating a political
headache for aaron o'toole who wants his
caucus to send a different message
vaccines are safe
you're right david and all of our mps
are are talking about that responsibly
and where people have not our caucus
will be addressing that we are
addressing that we all have a role to
play
now one of the mps who was recently
spreading misinformation about vaccines
that's ontario mp marilyn gladu she
issued an apology today and she did that
one day after o'toole publicly
criticized her for doing so that is the
power of the leader's office donna
and david aaron o'toole named his shadow
cabinet today who is in who's out and
what message does it send well first of
all let's look at who's out not in
shadow cabinet glad who was one of them
she had been health critic under andrew
scheer she didn't make the cut neither
did leslie lewis another vaccine skeptic
in caucus and that's a pretty clear sign
that o'toole is not going to feature any
mps that are offside on vaccines but he
is going to feature some strong caucus
members pierre paulier for example very
popular with the conservative base he
will be finance critic calgary mp
michelle rempel garner she's going to
champion alberta's oil and gas industry
as natural resources critic what o'tool
is trying to do put his best people up
against the strong performers in
trudeau's cabinet donna all right david
aiken in ottawa thanks
another search is underway for unmarked
graves of missing children this time in
ontario it's taking place on the grounds
of what was one of the longest running
residential schools in canada the mohawk
institute residential school in
brantford ontario was open from 1828
until 1970. it's located near the
territory of the six nations of the
grand river the search is being
conducted by members of the first nation
along with its own police service
trained to use ground penetrating radar
machines more than 200 hectares of land
will be searched
it's about justice right and it's about
it's about holding people accountable
it's about holding governments
accountable it's going to be tough
i mean it's these are the lives we're
talking about
right particularly children
more than 15 000 children were forced to
attend this school it was operated by
the anglican church until 1951 when the
federal government took it over
there is some support for survivors a
24-hour crisis line is available for
anyone experiencing pain or distress as
a result of their or a loved one's
residential school experience the number
is toll-free you can speak in confidence
it's 1-866-925-4419
there are only a few days left to hammer
out agreements at the u.n climate summit
in glasgow the goal is for participating
countries to agree on the rules to keep
the average global temperature from
rising more than 1.5 degrees above
pre-industrial levels well one new
analysis reveals efforts to avert a
climate catastrophe are already falling
short it forecasts global temperatures
are on track to rise 2.4 degrees by the
end of the century that's according to
the climate action tracker an
independent research group monitoring
progress on climate targets heather urex
west looks at why there is such a gap
and what more needs to be done
as the cop 26 climate summit enters its
final days a reality check even with the
latest pledges the world is still a long
way from reaching its climate goals
glasgow is meant to keep
the paris agreements 1.5 degree limit in
sight but the 2030 emissions gap is
still so huge that we can't really see
that being possible at present the
research coalition climate action
tracker looked at the promises made by
every country attending the global
climate summit finding existing promises
to cut greenhouse gas emissions by 2030
don't go far enough not a single country
has short-term policies in place to put
itself on track towards its own net zero
target with stakes so high negotiators
from nearly 200 countries will need to
ensure targets set at this summit will
be enough to turn the tide we are making
progress at cop 26 but we still have a
mountain to climb over the next few days
on wednesday countries will review the
summit's first draft document a summary
of every commitment made after more than
a week of talks the big thing we're
hoping to
want to see now is that
the final text of the cop 26
conference
has strong language around the need to
phase out fossil fuels
advocates for canada's fossil fuel
industry are in glasgow this week as
well i think that when we look at what
has created the biggest reductions to
this point it has been utilizing new
technologies
finding efficiencies displacing coal
with natural gas
all of these things need to be continued
canada has promised to legislate a cap
on emissions for the oil and gas
industry though we still don't know what
that cap will be
success at cop 26 will depend on the
strength of so many details and the
ability of nearly 200 countries to agree
heather eurix west global news calgary
drake breaks his silence about that
deadly concert coming up his emotional
instagram post after being accused of
inciting the crowd at astroworld
canadian rapper drake has posted a
statement after the deadly events at the
astro world music festival in houston on
instagram drake says i've spent the past
few days trying to wrap my mind around
this devastating tragedy he says my
heart is broken for the families and
friends of those who lost their lives
eight people died friday when the crowd
surged to the stage crushing fans drake
and travis scott were on stage and are
named in multiple lawsuits including for
allegedly inciting the crowd a criminal
investigation is underway scott is
promising refunds for all ticket holders
and says he will also cover funeral
costs
a grim new milestone in british columbia
that province is on track for its
deadliest year from overdoses of toxic
illicit drugs the bc coroner's service
says more than 1500 people died in the
first nine months of this year that's
the highest number ever recorded in that
time period it's a 24 increase from
2020. in september 152 deaths from
illicit drugs were recorded the 12th
month in a row with more than 150 deaths
last week bc became the first province
to officially request a federal
exemption to decriminalize the
possession of hard drugs
montreal canadians goalie carey price
has gone public with his treatment for
substance abuse price released a
statement saying he checked himself into
a residential treatment facility last
month on instagram the 34 year old
father of three says i am working
through years of neglecting my own
mental health which will take some time
to repair all i can do it is take it day
by day with that comes some uncertainty
with when i will return to play
price rejoined his teammates off the ice
today for the first time since october
seventh
ahead is belarus exploiting thousands of
desperate migrants as political pawns
[Music]
a grim situation is unfolding on the
border between poland and belarus the
president of belarus alexander
lukashenka is being accused of
exploiting migrants for political
purposes he's accused of using them as
pawns encouraging them to come to
belarus and promising they can enter
europe instead they're trapped in
freezing weather on the polish border
with no shelter or food crystal
gamansing reports
here on the border of poland and belarus
hundreds of desperate people are
stranded in the freezing cold where are
you going to poland yes
yes germany
why you go to germany
the country the good the good country
belarusian officials are accused of
luring migrants from the middle east and
africa with the promise of easy access
to europe the eu says what's happening
under president alexander lukashenko is
gangster-style behavior how lukashenko
regime
conducts this operation this very very
inhuman unacceptable and actually
illegal
operation is that they reach out to
potential clients to these potential
travelers through seemingly official
channels
between june and august the european
union followed by canada the uk and the
us imposed sanctions on lukashenko and
belarus for human rights abuses
belarus is accused of weaponizing
migrants in retaliation sending
thousands to the border to provoke
conflict
lukashenko however insists belarus is
the victim of an intimidation campaign
european commissioner president ursula
van der lion has threatened more
sanctions and warned third-party
countries involved could also be
included the president demanded very
clear with the statement that belarus
stops the instrumentalization of
migrants for political purposes which is
putting people's lives at risk
there are reports several migrants have
died but information is limited
journalists are not permitted on the
polish front lines with thousands of
soldiers guarding the crossing and
blockades in place
some longing to make it into europe are
heading to neighboring latvia and
lithuania
but soldiers there are also mobilizing
along border points with belarus
crystal gomencing global news
london
100 years of the poppy next how it
became such an enduring symbol
the poppy is the flower of remembrance
day and has been for so long we rarely
stop to think about why this year is the
100th anniversary of the poppy being
adopted as a visible way to honor the
fallen and raise money for veterans mike
derlay explains how the delicate crimson
flower became such an enduring symbol
how could anything grow in the ballast
guard fields of the first world war in
every direction mud and disease yet
amidst so much death life in the form of
a brilliant red poppy caught the eye of
john mccrae which he immortalized in the
poem in flanders fields and it really
contrasts with the you know the life and
the reality of what what it was like on
the western front in world war one the
poem became an inspiration the war
office in britain began using it as a
recruiting tool but it was a pair of
women on either side of the atlantic who
saw in the poppy the potential for
charity
in georgia moyna michael is known as the
founder of the memorial poppy for
convincing the american legion in 1920
to adopt it as its emblem of remembrance
but it was a french woman named anagera
who started it all first to raise funds
for children who were orphaned during
the war and then as the symbol for
veterans we know today
so having this the poppy um transcend
uh and become this vehicle of funding to
repair these men psychologically and
otherwise is an absolutely wonderful
thing and that certainly does get its
roots from garen crossing the atlantic
garden has been described as a natural
networker after seeing the success of
her charity back home in 1921 that poppy
lady from france convinced canadian
veterans in port arthur ontario which is
now thunder bay to adopt the poppy as
its symbol
today the legion receives over 20
million dollars a year in donations
that's become essential for veterans
programs and this being the 100th
anniversary the legion not only
recreated the 1921 poppy it's entered
the world of limited digital art with an
nft called the immortal poppy
essentially it is a digital poppy what
we did is we took an original genuine
poppy from flanders fields in belgium an
artist recreated that poppy in digital
format and now it exists in 100 copies
the names of one hundred and eighteen
thousand fallen canadians are printed on
the pedals a century of sacrifice and
charity intertwined
microlight global news toronto
global news will have live coverage of
the remembrance day ceremony in ottawa
our coverage starts at 10 30 a.m eastern
7 30 pacific it will also be streaming
on our website
globalnews.ca on november 11th that is
global national for this tuesday i'm
donna friesen we leave you tonight with
this cascade of handmade poppies draping
the niagara on the lake museum in
ontario it was put together by dozens of
volunteers from the community who spent
hours crocheting and knitting nearly 3
500 flowers to honor the fallen ahead of
remembrance day
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye-bye
[Music]